the middle-class mantra more than
anything else I just want to be
comfortable I don't know about you but I
was taught in high school in college all
throughout my academic career that hard
work equals success and the wealthy
laugh at that a shift takes place you've
desensitized to the word no and when
that happens it's magic you know I don't
think it'd work as hard for the
Corvette's in the fancy houses as you do
for milk
this dude was mean middle class thinkers
live in delusion world class thinkers
live in objective reality and I'm
thinking Muhammad Ali needed a bodyguard
you know and I gotta fight him this is
crazy this is not most people don't
really understand how how wealth is
built and I'll make you more money than
you pay me if I don't let me go in two
weeks if I do hire me I cannot fail I
can only learn and grow I don't want any
feedback I don't want any pushback just
do what the man tells you to do he's a
mental toughness coach two of his four
books on mental toughness are
international bestsellers his clients
include fortune 500 companies like
Johnson & Johnson Toyota and Procter &
Gamble he's been featured on The Today
Show Good Morning America CBS and Fox
he's Steve see bold and here are his top
10 rules for success so most of my life
this is where I fit right in the middle
class how do I know cuz that's the
results I got that's why if you really
want to know where you fit look at your
results in any given area you know if
you've been in the business two months
and you this business and you're you
just got licensed and you're saying well
I've gotten lower the middle-class
results we got to give yourself some
time right but over time look at your
results and they'll tell you where you
are in the classes the middle-class
mantra more than anything else
I just want to be comfortable oh just
let me be comfortable please God let me
be comfortable nothing wrong with it no
I'm not putting down not judging anyone
or anything like that this is just what
they tell us over and over and over want
to be comfortable and Larry Wilson a
good mentor of mine a friend says that
uh when so it's the middle-class thinker
gets the pearly gate st. Peter says
congratulations you've arrived safely at
death
one of our clients is a guy named
Charlie Idol Charlie is the CEO of
Simmons mattress company might have
heard of an the fantastic world-class
performer one of the darlings of the
fortune 500 and Charlie said one time I
was talking to him and he said you know
Steve we're talking about this
comfortable middle-class idea and he
said you know I thought about that for a
long time and he said when I abandon
that thought process that's when I
started my ascent to the top and I said
well tell me more Charlie because I love
to just probe these guys and find out
what's inside their mind because I know
it's different that I've been thinking
most of my life and that most of us
think and he said you know I'll give it
to you straight I never forgot this he
said I just didn't want to see myself
sitting in a nursing home one day
looking out the window thinking to
myself that I played it safe and I just
I just hit me like a Mack truck I
thought wow that's a pretty good idea
and I said well what did you do he says
I decided to go for it I started to
abandon fear and stop being comfortable
he said I learned I watched this he said
I learned Steve to be comfortable you
know what the finishes being
uncomfortable yeah they all say that
you've heard it I've heard it right over
and over and over I learned to get
comfortable being uncomfortable why
because I had to have the vision the
vision had to be fulfilled for my family
and myself had to happen wasn't taking
no for an answer and if it wasn't going
to happen there are no guarantees and I
ended up looking out the window at the
nursing home and I had a few bad breaks
and it just didn't happen at least I can
look out the window and say you know I
didn't make it
baby but I went for it I went for it I
was tough I was fearless I went for it
yeah it fell a little short life happens
sometimes you get bad breaks didn't
happen the way I wanted to but I went
for it that's got to be a pretty good
feeling even if you don't make it you
know I mean if you hope Philippe
be a pretty good feeling to know you did
everything you could to make it we trade
hours for dollars we're talking and I
don't know about you but I was taught in
high school in college all throughout my
academic career that hard work equals
success and the wealthy laugh at that I
mean they know hard work really doesn't
unless you're talking about hard work in
terms of thinking hard work really can
get you I mean my dad was a bricklayer
here in Chicago most of his life and he
worked really hard he made a good living
but certainly was never wealthy because
hard work typically doesn't hard
physical work especially doesn't equate
to wealth leverage creates wealth and
how do which people use leverage and how
do they use their thought process to get
rich well they leverage everything it's
one of the greatest lessons I ever
learned from the wealthy in the last 26
years of interviews they leverage their
education their contacts their knowledge
their money they leverage everything to
help them build greater wealth I work
with primarily with sales peoples of
large very large corporations fortune
500 sales forces that's what I do pretty
much every day and you would guess this
you might be in that area or maybe not
but you'd probably guess that the
biggest problem that they all have
across the board anywhere in the world
we work is the fear of rejection right
why well psychologists say it's because
most of us have the greatest addiction
you can possibly have and that's the
addiction to the approval of other
people it works when we're children but
we carry it into adulthood and it causes
most of us to stop asking people to buy
or to get in ilg or to marry us or to
dance with us or whatever it is we're
addicted to this approval of other
people I think my friend Dan Carroll
talked about this a little bit earlier
on well the world class have a secret
and this one you know people say secrets
everything's a secret some of its not
this one is a little bit of a secret at
least that I found among where
glass salespeople and here it is this is
a beauty they overcome this addiction
through a process that psychologists
call systematic desensitization
systematic desensitization now granted
these are the two biggest words I know I
get that but but it sounds complicated
but it's really not here is how it works
systematically over time they
desensitize to hearing the word know
yeah see at first you ask to buy yes I'm
gonna buy ask someone to get an ilg
whatever it is and they say no one you
go oh like Terry just talked about ooh
feeling the pain emotional pain but
after you ask and you ask and you ask
and you ask psychologically all of a
sudden a shift takes place you've
desensitized to the word no and when
that happens it's magic it's a big part
of the mental toughness process and a
big part of the secrets of the world
class especially in sales once it
happens they start to see everything as
a game once you start to see asking
someone to get in ilg selling a product
or service or whatever it is you do you
start to see it as a game you no longer
associate emotional pain with the word
no and then what happens as a result you
start asking everyone and you get very
dangerous and you also can get very rich
doing that exact thing anyone seen the
movie I just watching the plane coming
down from Atlanta yesterday
Cinderella man he's seeing that did you
see the clip I thought it was I was it
was very emotional you know movie don't
you think I'm on the plane metal
toughest guy geez guys thanks we going
what's wrong now you want to clean it
geez you know as a tough movie but the
part I liked the most was which makes
this point just beautifully and I never
I had never seen it before but when he's
in the ring I forget which fight it is
but when he's in the ring he's supposed
to lose
and he he's losing he's getting beat up
by some big guy and he and he sees his
kids freezing in the depression and no
food you remember that he sees it in his
mind and he then he wins the fight
because it drives him because he's
thinking I got a fight
to keep the lights on and the this is
1930s right during the Great Depression
my kids are starving and I have no heat
and he's living in New Jersey and he
flashes if you haven't seen him over he
flashes this on his mind he's in that
he's in the ring he's sitting there
going ready to go back in and he's
sitting there and he flashes this
picture of his kids and they're freezing
and they work this is the truth this is
what was happening couldn't afford to
pay his light belt I mean is that his
electric belt and he saw it so he came
out there like King Kong and the net the
next day and the predator story and the
press conference the next day they said
one of the reporters goes off turn
remember his name what was his name the
carrot the holds his name to buy the
fighter cherry yeah J James J Braddock
thank you so there in the press
conference and someone says oh mr.
Braddock I got a question for you so go
ahead what happened to you three years
ago you couldn't fight you know you can
beat up anyone I mean what happened and
Braddock said a mentally tough thing
that all these world-class performers
have this is that this is the golden
secret of this process you guys I
promise you he said now I know what I'm
fighting for and he said what are you
fighting for
and he said milk
silence in the room because a couple
days before he picked up the milk you
know they delivered the milk back then
right and it had the overdue notice on
the bottle so it couldn't pay the milk
kids can't have milk come fight for milk
you want to go up against the guy who's
fighting for milk I don't want to I
don't want that's a beam gun beam do it
man you know you know I don't think it'd
work as hard for the Corvette's in the
fancy houses as you do for milk
this dude was mean he wasn't digging no
for an answer and he didn't it's a heck
of a story if you haven't seen a
Cinderella that's a great movie that's
very moving emotionally but that's what
it is I think that's what I found anyway
most people don't know why they're
running in the house so why should I
fight the enemy of the champion is
delusion middle class thinkers live in a
state of mild delusion especially when
it comes to their careers the average
person believes they are far more
competent at what they do for a living
than they actually are many people
believe they're overworked and underpaid
and this is rarely true in a free-market
economy we are normally getting paid
very close to what we're worth employers
aren't stupid they're not going to pay a
hundred thousand dollars a year for a
job that's only worth 75 thousand if
they did they wouldn't be in business
very long compensation is based on
supply and demand
so if you're not getting paid what you
believe you're worth you're always free
to lease your professional services to
another organization here's my point and
this may be offensive to some of you but
remember that this is mental toughness
not Club Med okay middle-class thinkers
live in delusion
world class thinkers live in objective
reality the world class thinker knows
that her compensation is directly
related to the number or size of
problems she is solving for an
organization if she wants to make more
money she asks for the opportunity to
solve more problems or larger more
complex problems and that's all there is
to it champions take full responsibility
for the results and that includes the
compensation they receive for the work
they do so the first step in the process
of becoming a world-class performer and
catapulting your compensation is to get
into objective reality in regards to how
much the services you perform are
really worth the secret is to remove all
emotion from this thought process and
see what you do for a living strictly
from the eyes of the people who pay you
to do it the first critical thinking
question to ask yourself is how
difficult would it be to replace you the
second question is how much would it
cost to replace you and the final
question is what would you have to do to
double your income in the next 12 to 24
months once you begin asking critical
thinking questions like these you've
already started the process of
differentiating yourself from your
competition and if you're not sure of
the answers scheduled a short meeting
with your boss
the downside of getting into objective
reality is it can be painful to face the
truth the upside is you know exactly
where you stand and precisely what you
need to do to dramatically increase your
pay talk to most middle-class thinkers
and they'll swear to you that their
company is paying them the least amount
of money they have - the truth is your
employer would love to make you rich
they'll gladly pay you more money than
you can spend if you can help them solve
complex problems no one else can several
years ago I took up kickboxing great
workout lots of fun so I'm in the
kickboxing club one day and the owner
comes up to me he says Steve would you
like me to set you up with a sparring
partner so you'll have someone to
practice what I said yeah sure
so he introduces me to this guy named
Big Jim this guy is six foot four 300
pounds solid muscle
no no kidding he says Steve not only is
Big Jim the three-time armwrestling
champion of the world but he was
Muhammad Ali's bodyguard back in the 70s
and I'm thinking Muhammad Ali needed a
bodyguard you know and I gotta fight him
this is crazy this is not so I'm in the
ring with this monster I'm in the ring
with them this is like the Hulk Hogan
versus pee-wee Herman not good so I'm in
the ring I'm bouncing around doing my
little thing I learned at the kickboxing
Club right you know punching and kick in
and do a nice he's not even swinging at
me he's just walking
it's got this big chest like this
squawking around like this looking mean
and at one point he goes go ahead you
can hit me as hard as you want and I
already was so so I'm bouncing around
like this and finally he starts to look
like he's he's getting mad and his face
got a little red and he goes look you
got three seconds to give me your best
shot
like we're on the street you got three
seconds or I'll knocking you out like
where's the owner where's the owner come
back help me I didn't know what to do I
mean what would you have done right so
I'm bouncing around like this going I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I
don't what to do how to do and finally I
went oh yeah and I punch this gorilla as
hard as I could right in the groin yeah
it was a good shot too he catches my
fist in the palm of his giant hand now
his face is beet red the veins in his
neck are bulging out and I said I'm dead
aren't I and he said you would be if we
around the street I was like cool thank
God he said there was a really stupid
move what were you thinking
I say you scared me I'm a tennis player
you scared me I don't know what to do
hey
and he says Steve look look think about
it I got at least a hundred pounds on
you I've been fighting professionally
for 30 years he says Steve you're
fighting a fight you can't win the only
way to win a fight you can't win is not
the fight you should have run out of the
ring is that where were you two minutes
ago when I needed you you know but I
thought to myself that is nonlinear
thinking it never crossed my mind it
never crosses most people's minds
because we're trained as you know to
think linear right in school abc123
linear thinking when we all know the big
problems of the world
I really solved with nonlinear
big thinking it's one of the great
secrets of the world class I learned in
25 years of interviewing these people
all over the world keep an open mind
keep an open mind and be careful who
you're associating with because most
people don't understand how money works
it's just the thinking about money where
and again I I didn't either I'm not
standing out from you know talking from
an ivory tower I didn't get it either
but when most people don't really
understand how how wealth is built and
so start listening to wealthy people
open your mind and start listening to
wealthy people and associate with them
through books seminars CDs whatever you
possibly can to get to get exposure to
their consciousness alright so if you're
stuck in the middle class role how do
you change your mindset to get into the
world class role well that's that's
exactly what I did 26 years ago and I
started the process I think first of all
you have to you have to learn how rich
people think and how it's very different
than the average person and after again
all these interviews all over the world
it's like these two groups are living on
different planets and how you operate in
a completely different mind space yeah
well and and sometimes it seems like
when when you're struggling to make
money it seems like you're always
struggling to make money and you say
that that that is just a repetitive
behavior a typical in the middle class
right sure it's like right now the
unemployment is so high and people are
thinking I want a job how can I get a
job but there are no jobs the rich would
think think like a rich person instead
now the rich don't need jobs but but if
they did need a job I'll tell you
exactly what they would do because I
know so many of them they would go to a
store and say how can I make your cash
register ring you don't have to pay me
for the first two weeks I'll sell I'll
do customer calls I'll stock shelves
it's better than sitting at home and
I'll make you more money than you pay me
if I don't let me go in two weeks if I
do hire me I cannot fail
I can only learn and grow cannot fail
I can only learn and grow and I got that
one from our fellow algae faculty member
Superman himself Larry Wilson I
interviewed Larry many years ago and he
said Steve there really is no failure he
said it's all a stepping stone to the
next level I didn't get it at the time I
get it now I think I get it I got a call
from
and Wall Street and I hid it's a very
fast growing one of the fastest growing
companies on Wall Street and the
interesting thing about it to me is that
they make a lot of money and they're
growing super fast but the average age
is about 25 as far as their salespeople
call and they're just hungry they're
just like you guys are hungry they're
young and they just don't take no for an
answer so they called me and asked me to
keynote do a keynote speech at their
National Convention in Atlantic City a
couple years ago so I did it had a great
time they were 300 of their top
salespeople qualified for this deal and
it was it was just a group about the
size as a matter of fact fantastic great
people a lot of fun and I never heard
from again that just I just did a speech
and that's what they wanted so I get a
call from the president who's 39 years
old he's a self-made billionaire 39
years old started from scratch nice guy
tough as nails mentally tough focused
like you can't believe he calls me up
and he says Steve I got a problem and I
said okay what's happening he said well
I tell you what since Atlantic City baby
Hall we're making money oh oh it's good
I mean I got 300 of the richest
salespeople on Wall Street we're
cranking man it's just going really well
I said all right what's the problem it
sounds pretty good to me why'd he call
it he said I have twenty five-year-old
sales people going to the emergency room
with chest pains he said you're the
mental toughness guy can you help and I
said I don't know I don't know let me
think about it I'll get back to you so
I'm driving home from the office at
night to my house and Einstein's quote
came into my head a problem cannot be
solved in the same level of
consciousness or thinking in which it
occurs so I thought okay these
salespeople are going to the emergency
room because they're they're putting
this pressure that we talked about
earlier with the balloon right on
themselves doesn't exist in the universe
but in their minds it exists perception
is reality yeah so I know it's a very
low level of consciousness but they
can't see it can't see the forest for
the trees like Einstein talked about so
I thought okay
I've got something called Michael back
the next day I said I think I got an
answer for you didn't even ask me what
it is this is great I'll see you in New
York just believe the guy is is amazing
so I went to New York and I went to
their office 300 there top salespeople
and you have to sort of see this office
to believe it it's up I guess it's about
the size of a football field it's one
level and they work in these like half
cubicles you can still see all the
salespeople to like ants when you go up
on the top and look down and they're all
over the place and you can see them all
but it's like one floor and it's like
the most intense thing they have this
big alarm that goes off when the market
opens and they start selling and they
sell by phone and this is kind of what
it sounds like it's the best I can do
they work with these headsets and they
had these appointment centers I guess
you call them up on these risers and
they say okay I've got John Smith on on
line six go and they wear these headsets
like this in the in a pace like like
Tigers in a cage it's like it so it's
white you got to see it to believe it
okay talk to me baby just six and a half
percent I can't make any money on you
you're killing me T's not be reasonable
John theory we've been doing business
for years you won't let me make any
money I just draw like this all the time
and they're good but they're tense
they're tense so I came up with this
idea as crazy idea so Michael gets up
there the president he says all right
you guys fall and fall in the same sizes
crowd as you guys and they're all
standing by their cubicle they got the
Armani suits on the Gucci fancy whatever
suits and the alligator $2,000 shoes and
the fancy dresses and the whole
understanding they're looking at me now
I knew him from Atlantic City but not
all that look like they might attack at
any time I wasn't sure little worried
about that but they're staying about
their cubicle ever right before the
market opens and they're looking at
their watches and Michael goes all right
you guys falling he said look I'm not
gonna waste any time introducing Steve
Sebold you already met him in Atlantic
City this is a Leeteuk her dude you
ready met him so let's not waste any
time just get to it here's the bottom
line
I don't know what he's gonna tell you
cuz he hasn't even told me but this is
this is
at the end of the day this is what it is
you guys I don't want any feedback I
don't want any pushback just do what the
man tells you to do he's a mental
toughness coach just do what he tells
you to do
anything says pointing people up you
just don't ESET just for you
and then he goes alright Steve you're on
my training show yeah thank you Wow team
away from Florida for this so I got up
there and they're all looking at me
pretty mean and everything if you ever
see the movie Wall Street go up Michael
does Gordon
this is 300 Gordon Gekkos nice people
they're really nice but they're tough as
nails so I was like before I said that
you know these guys eat their young kind
of same kind of thing so I walk up and
they're all looking at me real seriously
and I said okay guys I said well let me
first of all congratulate you on your
success Wow
whoo since I seen you in Atlantic City
you know just great things
congratulations I'm not going to change
anything you're doing in sales because
obviously you're doing it you're doing
it darn well great job I'm just going to
add a couple of things today and then
I'm going to let you sell and do just
what you do every day you're not gonna
change a thing
just a couple additions so if you'll
reach under your desk you'll see one of
these moose head masks
he just seemed to look at me I had to
keep a straight face or I can't laugh
blow the whole thing should and so so if
you reach under there and get the moose
head mask and I say that I've had these
custom-made on the west coast and you
can they go right over your headphones I
said so just go ahead and put the moose
head mask on over these are Wall Street
killers put it over your head set none
just it's got the little velcro straps
which are very convenient for this so
put them on there put the boat go on and
then and then you shouldn't look it I
had to keep you straight face all the
time so I'm like okay I'm wanting a
laugh but I can't laugh so I said no now
once y'all putting it on
they didn't say anything no yet so so I
said all right now now one of the things
is you have to pull the top down because
it's important that you see the little
eyes that's very important you get the
whole effect here so pull those down and
all of a sudden what I'm said Michael
what's the deal come on what is this one
and Michael jumps are you those guys I
told you what's it always said
yet the mascot to us on and a lot to it
clapping her uh and I gotta keep a
straight face it's on back they're going
don't laugh Steve don't laugh metal
toughest control don't laugh so so sorry
guys
okay go ahead Steve I said alright
everyone having a okay looks good those
look good just keep the antlers up
that's good and they're all can having
so if you're reaching your front drawer
just one other thing I'll let you guys
sell I don't want to stop your selling
here there's one of these clown noses
and it's it's a it's a it's a one size
fits all which is convenient so just put
the nose on keep yours up guy keep the
ears up that's you gotta have that so
and that's it they're all looking at me
I can't laugh so I said that's it just
do what you do all day long don't change
a thing all you have to do is just keep
the antlers on and the nose well debrief
at 4 o'clock when the market closes and
we'll go from there
good luck go sell something and you guys
without even missing a beat get John
Smith online - lets go they forgot all
about it
ok now come on can we do some business
here today cuz you're killing me man
I mean I don't know I don't know why I
came into work I can't make any money on
you oh geez
it all sudden they break they look out
they'd see the antlers going across the
office they just bring out laughs and be
like I'm separating I'm not laughing at
you John huh I call you back I'll call
you back I'm sorry I'm not laughing at
you
this went on for eight solid hours
it was one of the funniest things I
should have brought these guys the film
crew with me I should be I didn't film
it that I shut up can you imagine I
could have sold it on television it
didn't the new reality show Wall Street
the reality or something like that so at
the end of the day I we did the debrief
they went through the whole day with it
and they kept it on they did exactly
what I asked them to do at the end of
the day we had him up here they were
standing I said all right you guys great
job today what did you learn remember
young group all under 40 years old sales
be most him in their 20s and elect some
of the people here as a matter of fact
so little guy in the back of there maybe
21 22 years old raising his hand like
this I said go ahead and he said I got
it I got it
message received said okay what would
you would you get he said well yeah
lighten up we got a light mouth I mean
yeah we're all making all this money and
this is all fantastic and we're living
our dream and hey great it's not worth
dying in the process for let's lighten
up and still be successful and not die
not go to the hospital with chest pains
it's not worth it
let's remember to lighten up message
received thank you and I said there it
is that's the end of it
debrief over said so here's a know why
Anna do as you go forward just take this
mask don't change anything you're doing
obviously with your selling but take
this this mask and put it on the corner
we just lost South America down here got
a little frog down there in Brazil I
don't know what's happened ha ha
you never know it's going to have on
you're on stage I'm telling you just got
to be prepared for everything so I told
him I say I said put the you know put
the mask in your desk and then when you
get really tense and the pressures
mounting and you're thinking these
low-level thoughts then just remember to
lighten thank you so much for watching I
made this video because unis iboga asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you are made of profound next
leaving the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know
which is Steve's top ten rules is gonna
make you think the most what thoughts
are coming up to watching some of those
clips I'd really love to know leaving
the comments below and I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching and continue to believe and
I'll see you soon